[Music]
this wildlife refuge was established for
the protection of native fishes eight
species of native rio yaki fishes
[Music]
the jaguar occurs in the rio yaki down
all of these drainages now these
drainages are completely dammed up
we're going to cease to see jaguars in
the u.s if they complete all of these
border walls
currently there's one roaming around the
dos cabezas chiricahua swiss helm
mountains
could be stuck here
there you go
now
this is where
what i call the easter egg hunt
see what you get we put these cameras
out here because there were reports from
refuge personnel that they were seeing a
lot of wildlife moving through the
refuge
every time i would come to check these
cameras this winter there'd be a couple
mountain lions lots of bobcats more
javelina than you could shake a stick at
and now there's like nothing i checked
this camera now and there was one skunk
out of
1641 pictures
the wall is not even completed and we're
already seeing a pretty pronounced
effect
yeah this is personal
i wake up at 4am with images of this
border wall
that are just burned into my head
it's going to be that feeling like when
somebody you love has died i'm watching
the the destruction of nature i'm
watching the systematic destruction of
nature
[Music]
including all the water they're using
you know million gallons a day
it's really a crime against nature and
it's a crime against this country
i really wish that that the rest of
america would see this
[Music]
[Music]
you